say hi to YouTube hi YouTube hey
everyone what's happening I'm sorry I've
been a little m.i.a recently I got sick
last week and my parents visiting and
work was really busy but I am back in
full force today I wanted to answer a
common question that I've gotten from so
many of you do you need to be good at
math to be a software engineer the
overall answer that I've been giving to
everyone and I'm just gonna tell you
right now is no you don't have to be
great at math to be a software engineer
but you do have to be able to reason
logically okay my you go but what do you
mean by that well other than my you go I
am going to dive into that today I want
to note that I am a mobile engineer and
happen for my whole career and so I
don't have very much expertise in the
other areas and software engineering and
so I'm going to try my best to talk
about them if you are in these other
areas of software engineering I would
love for you to leave a comment down
below explaining how you use math in
your jobs so let's jump in first of all
there are several different kinds of
software engineering jobs out there you
could be a mobile engineer a
infrastructure engineer well this list
isn't exhaustive I would say these are
the most common types of software
engineering jobs and all of these
require different technologies and
different areas of expertise in software
engineering and it's because of this
diversity in software engineering jobs
that you can be working on some really
math heavy stuff or not at all game
engineers to my knowledge use a lot of
math in their jobs as they use code to
model the laws of physics in their games
for instance writing code for how
gravity works when a player jumps up and
down or how light should reflect on the
character from different angles in
contrast I write apps that require very
little math the code involved is usually
making an app out of parts that apple
provides and usually taking data from a
database and showing them in a
user-friendly manner in an app one thing
however that is common to all areas of
software engineering
in terms of math is the ability to
reason logically code is just a series
of logical statements and so logical
reasoning is really important for
reading writing and fixing code
so while math could be important to a
software engineering job it usually
plays an integral part in computer
science related degrees most
universities require college-level math
classes as a prerequisite to take more
advanced computer science classes at my
school I remember needing to take
calculus differential equations
linear algebra and probability and
statistics also some computer science
classes are more math heavy than others
and some require needing to do fifth
wise calculations and others vector
calculus but it makes sense that they
require these things because a computer
science degree is set up so that you can
go into any field of software
engineering although I don't use most of
the math you topics I learned in college
they did serve as a very strong
foundation for me to get into any
software engineering career that I was
passionate about so to sum this all up
most universities will require a decent
amount of college-level mathematics
courses and math knowledge for CS
classes but depending on which software
engineering career you choose a strong
foundation in math could be really
important to your day to day job but it
also could not be the most important
thing to remember though is that logical
reasoning is probably the most important
math related skills for any software
engineering job again if you have had
any different experiences from my own
please leave a comment down below and
let us know what your experience has
been cool that's it and thank you so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this video I know that math can be kind
of a scary topic and especially if you
want to go into software engineering it
can be kind of the big wall but I hope
this inspired you with that said thank
you so much to everyone who has liked
commented and shared my video and also
sent me a message you all continue to be
my biggest motivator in the scary new
adventure called YouTube
I'm working on a couple videos and one
of those videos is a Q&A with my friend
Jarvis who's also a software engineer
we'd love to answer your questions
mainly around college and studying
computer science so if you can shoot me
a tweet at hello my you go or use the
hashtag ask me you go we will hopefully
be able to answer your questions in this
video all right I'll see you next time
and have a good day
[Music]